faut garder son calme mais se tenir
prêts c'est un peu ce que maxime et sa
copine rachel ont choisi de faire après
tout dit maxime la guerre avec la russie
a commencé depuis longtemps déjà
la guerre a commencé il ya huit ans dit
il alors on s'est habitué
la guerre est en cours depuis
l'occupation de la crimée et ces
derniers temps ils ont fait de l'ordre
dans leur document ont fait préparer un
passeport pour le chat et en cas d'
attaque russe à kiev le jeune couple
n'en portera que le strict minimum
qu'ils ont déjà bien rangés dans des
sacs à disposition du staff of
stuff l'idée c'est de prendre très peu
de choses dit il c'est quelque chose de
grave arrive comme des bombardements je
n'ai qu'à prendre mon sac le maître mon
ordinateur et me mettre à l'abri
c'est une angoisse sourde et résigné
mais surtout un refus de céder à la
panique et de laisser les tensions des
manoeuvres militaires aux frontières du
pays asphyxié le quotidien qu'on sent
bien à kiev
bien sûr je m'inquiète cette femme j'ai
des enfants des garçons qui sont en âge
d'être appelés à se battre
mais ce n'est pas comme si j'y pensais
sans arrêt la vie continue il y a autre
chose dont on doit s'occuper
ce banquier à la retraite a moins peur
des bombes et des armes que des dommages
bien réelle que la russie pourrait
infliger à l'ukraine sans même que le
sol ne soient foulés par le bot de ses
soldats
en plus des mesures économiques et la
russie pourraient prendre comme un
blocus de l'énergie des ressources comme
le gaz et l'électricité du bélarus dit
il ça pourrait vraiment joué sur notre
situation économique
mais je vois les troupes russes ou
frontières comme un pistolet sur notre
tante
si les manoeuvres militaires se
poursuivent de part et d'autre et avec
elle les accusations de provocation les
efforts diplomatiques n'en demeure pas
mois
dans toutes les grandes capitales les
coups de fil les visioconférences
poursuivre les visites ici à kiev de
dirigeant aussi c'était au tour du
président de la turquie hier donne
aujourd'hui de rencontrer le président
et minsky pour offrir ses services de
médiateur les ukrainiens ici à kiev se
disent très reconnaissants du soutien de
la communauté internationale
même si certains craignent que l'ukraine
ne finisse par pays fille trop élevé
pour une solution diplomatique
la plus grande crainte de ce chien de
garde de la démocratie de la
transparence dans la politique
ukrainienne c'est que les efforts
diplomatiques force l'ukraine a cédé aux
demandes de la russie quelle qu'elle
soit les ukrainiens ne saurait
l'accepter prévient-il
déstabiliser la société ukrainienne est
miné la confiance que nous avons envers
le gouvernement c'est précisément ce que
cherche l'agresseur russe aujourd'hui
ils vont se servir de ça comme d'une
excuse pour que leurs troupes
envahissent et se présentent comme des
casques bleus venus faire la paix
la meilleure défense des ukrainiens
croit-il et donc de rester unis et
solidaires la russie elle restera
toujours une épée de damoclès au dessus
du cren ici marie-eve bédard radio
canada qui m